hey what's up this is john with the dr
john baloney show i hope you're doing
awesome and i've tried to not say the
word awesome anymore i had a buddy tell
me that's what like people who work with
high school kids say like oh that's
awesome i'm trying not to say it but i
just said it i'm sorry but i'm so glad
you're with us
listen the special show
it's the 100th episode show we've done a
hundred of these things
we've gone from delony does not have
social media and does not know how
instagram works which according to some
of you who write into me
still don't know how that works to we
have crossed the hundreds show mark
we are off to the races and um
i'm i can't even tell you this is so
surreal
it's it's been a mind-bender i'm so
grateful for everybody who listens to
this show who tells their friends hey
you gotta listen to this episode
you gotta go check this guy out i'm so
so so grateful thank you so so much so
here's the deal
in my nerd world uh when i was a
researcher nerd and an academic
guy what i was really fascinated by was
quote unquote people that had made it
right doctors lawyers people who are
winning in business
um faith leaders folks
in communities that other people look to
them
for answers how do i be well what i need
to be doing now
and what i was always fascinated by was
the more successful people became
the lonelier they got the tighter their
circles became
and suddenly they start seeing the world
a little bit differently they start
acting a little bit differently
their world starts orbiting other things
that
most of us don't understand and here's
the thing
when you get behind the the the fake
lives and the plastic lives and the
curtains
i found out there were people just like
me and it gave me a lot of peace and it
changed my
the way i blamed people for stuff and
pointed fingers at people for stuff and
so
here's the thing there's a hundred epis
a hundredth
episode is that how you say that james
hundredth it's the hundredth episode
it's the one zero zero th
episode and i thought man
my love for sitting down with somebody
and having a deep conversation that
people have never heard before
getting to the question and the story
behind the question behind the story
and my love for digging into folks who
have quote unquote made it
i'm so excited dave ramsey himself joins
me on today's show
talks about some things i don't think
he's ever talked about publicly
talks about how things fell apart
scorched earth and he had to
rebuild from the floor up and some of
the things he did intentionally
some of the things he still worries
about struggles about some of the things
that he still does in his life every day
to make sure he's whole and he's well
and what grief looks like what
loneliness all of it we go there and i'm
so
excited i'm so grateful that you joined
me on the show and i'm really excited
to let you guys see what i get to see on
a daily basis which is
the guy behind the microphone right when
the microphones turned off
and i'm just so thrilled so stay tuned
it's it's it's a wild ride
by the way um he said one of his
favorite songs was the eagles and so we
don't have a favorite song on this one
and so just sing your favorite eagle
song and just assume that was the song
of the day
cool stay in school don't do drugs this
is dave ramsey on the hundredth episode
of the dr john dolone's show
it's good to see you man
dude you too john i am the worst i i
watch some of my colleagues you
y'all are so good at getting into shows
and out of shows and there's two minutes
left and nobody knows
there's this whole piano playing that's
going on that
the average listener has no idea and
there is no more awkward person in this
building than me
and getting into a show getting out of
it it's like hey well it's overseas
we could probably get him some pump
music james no we don't know we're good
i don't i don't have some bass saxophone
it's all about that bass that's i i just
can't
anyway so it's good to see you man you
too um
so in in obviously this show is very
similar to your show but very very
different too where we
get a lot of calls about questions but
the goal here is to get behind that
question and to talk to the people
that these questions are happening too
right and often people think
this is the thing that's going on in my
life it's not all right there's other
things going on
and if i get deeper than that one of the
things that i've i've noticed over the
last 15 20 years is
people operate every day with these
words that are running through their
heads all day
but they don't have a picture for what
that reality looks like and they think
that everyone in their world around them
has got it more together everything's
going great everything's looking
wonderful and if someone's got a radio
shows on tv or they have an exercise
program whatever it is
they don't experience all these other
things that are really just
normal everyday run-of-the-mill
experiences that we all as people
are experiencing all the time right and
so i love
this segment we've had some some
few interviews on the show but i love
having these conversations where
we can take somebody who's got a persona
got a
public face if you will you have less of
a persona you're kind of who you are who
you are
but then say um tell me about
elaborate this for the listener right
give somebody some some a ringside seat
as to what this experience was like so i
appreciate you coming on the show
um just for the average person obviously
someone's listening to this show they
know who you are
give us the the the story right the
story that is the
the arc of the that began the ramsay
the ramsay the get out of debt the baby
steps that i want to be a part of
helping other people
take us back to that original story
sharon and i graduated from college we
were broke
she was driving a pinto that's how broke
we were
this is a bad car john and
um i went through i got fired from a job
um still don't know why i got fired the
guy just came in cussed at me and threw
me out there i probably did something
that i deserved but i wish he just told
me he's
dead now and i won't i'll never know why
you'll never know me bitter
but i got fired and i came home and i
always been around the real estate
business mom and dad were in the
business i got my license when i turned
18. so i thought i'm going the real
estate business i'm gonna
and so i went to work for a builder for
a while and then i decided to start
buying and selling
real estate and then nothing down real
estate seminars and
uh the this is actually before there
were actual infomercials
to tell you how to do it you know and
and but i went to these nothing down
seminars which were
hokey and but but what it did is it made
me believe i could do it
and so uh i bought our first
investment property at 23 years old by
the time i was 26 i had four million
dollars worth
you've hit kids uh now the kids came
later okay
and the uh and so
we um you know so you're 26 year old
millionaire
yeah and uh no more pinto but i borrowed
um
it was all borrowed money i mean it
borrowed three million dollars to get
the four million dollars worth so three
minus
i mean four minus three is one so i'm
i'm a millionaire but it's all in real
estate so i got no cash at all
i mean i had spare cash flying around i
was making a couple hundred a year
which in 1983 was a lot of money but uh
uh
but uh you know i worked all the time
and i was an arrogant little
uh person and um
you can say it on this show man and uh
yeah i own the show so i probably
shouldn't
but um but the uh um but anyway i
uh yeah and so i'm driving to jaguar i
thought i was all kind of
ba right i thought i was something else
and um
all worried about how everything looked
i met god on the way up
when you said that what does that mean i
mean i started
going to a church and i fell in love
with jesus and i got baptized and i
started learning the bible which i knew
nothing about
and it started changing me
and along that story arc of course the
banks got sold to another
bank and they called our notes we had a
lot of short-term notes because we were
doing flips
so we have a 90-day note and if the
house didn't sell we just renew it
for nine more days until it sold but all
of a sudden they said after 90 days we
won all our money
and so i mean the whole thing this house
of cards came crashing down
and we almost made it um i paid the
three million down to
uh down to under three hundred thousand
dollars
whoa and i almost made it but two and a
half years and one year i made 250 000
the next year i made six
thousand dollars my taxable income is
and that's the year rachel was born
and that's the year we filed bankruptcy
was the last year because we couldn't
make the term we had too many lawsuits
and too many people coming after us
they're coming to take the
baby bed out of the house and it just
it just destroyed any
sense of ego or confidence or
the word you would use is trauma
traumatized me
uh but but in the midst of it uh you
know i see we always
use the phrase around here but it's very
true is uh
matt got on the way up got to know him
on the way down and
um our marriage is hanging on by a
thread sharon would have left but she
didn't have a car i mean rachel's born
we got a toddler denise
and um rachel's middle right yeah rachel
had two
yeah rachel was born in april we filed
bankruptcy in september
and september was the end of the two and
a half year fight and how old
how much older is denise than rachel
three years
so one of the most common calls we get
on this show is hey my marriage is a
mess
and when i back out and say all right
sir give me some details they say
well we got two kids under three and i
always stop and say your life's a mess
anyway
right just hang on because it's gonna
yeah but yeah i mean sure you had that
sharon was a single mom with two babies
okay because you're running i'm just
running around working 60 hours a week
selling stuff trying to keep from going
bankrupt and trying to eat and trying to
keep the lights on and
they weren't kept on they got cut off
and they keep the water on and it wasn't
cut out
you know and um i mean we were so broke
of course i'm handy because i was always
working on houses my whole life and so
uh when they cut the water off i had a
water meter tool i just went cut it back
on right um
and then they came out and cut it off
and put a lock on it and i took my bolt
cutters got the lock off and cut it back
on
and then they came out and took the
water meter out oh man
so uh they don't they don't like you
it's killing me
if you're not paying the d if you're not
paying the bill so eventually i had to
pay the bill and
i was i mean i'm trying to feed my
family i mean i was broke
and uh it was not anything i'm proud of
but i really did do that
and uh if i could have figured out i'd
do that with the electric
meter i would have done that too but i
couldn't figure it out without getting
electrocuted and dying
so i mean we had the lights cut off we
had everything we stuff
towed we had we were foreclosed on we
were sued and it was just
two and a half years of unmitigated hell
and when we went bankrupt i'll never
forget
um we i've been so scared for so long
and i didn't know i was scared and i was
so broken and
i just stand in the shower and cry and i
remember driving away i could show you
the stop light on charlotte pike where i
was here in nashville i was driving away
from this little attorney's office
and we just signed the paperwork and
when you file bankruptcy it puts a stay
a stop on all collector activity all
creditor activity they can no longer
contact you
and i've been battling these guys with
clubs and knives and bazookas for
two and a half years day in and day out
been lied to stepped on kicked
spit on and deserved most of it and
i'm sitting at that stoplight i'm 28
years old with a brand new baby
i don't have any way to make money i'm
out of business
i had an incredible peace
wash over me it's like the other side
of the trauma this thing just washed
over me
and i thought man i can breathe i'm
gonna be okay
i don't know what i'm gonna do but i'm
gonna be okay i don't know we're gonna
get food next week
but we're gonna be okay once i don't
have i don't have this monkey on my back
anymore yeah that's one of the most
common things i hear people are going
through something
and you realize i haven't exhaled for
two years yeah i haven't
yeah i haven't looked my kid in the eye
in two years right i mean
my countenance changed literally
in six months i mean it was a spiritual
piece yes
um and but it's just getting that crap
off of us
and so when somebody calls my show 30
years later now
and i can hear it i can hear it just
like you can hear it on this show
well i watch you you've done enough
trauma work i mean you can hear somebody
you're hearing between the lines when
they're faking it the nervous laugh or
whatever
and i i can tell when they're when when
they're getting ready to start crying
because i can feel it i know that i know
what it feels like to have that lump in
your throat right
well and that's the difference between
reading a book about something and
having sutton in that
seat and stared at that stop light yeah
right and taking that oh man i haven't i
haven't exhaled in two years right or
three years
and when i hear a
you know a phoenix from the ash's story
like i'll
hear this and now we look at this
building right you got a thousand
employees we just built the other
building for the other two
like you've been a part of this
not been a part of you orchestrated this
extraordinary journey since then
when i look at a story like this or i
look at the super weight loss story or i
look at the
fill in the blank story what i always
think is man that must have been tough
then look how great so i got a model and
i got a map now
from here to here and then i go
like weight loss or exercise then i go
the next morning and i just work out as
hard as i can
i go do it and then that next morning
i'm so sore i can't move
yeah and then the only thing that makes
that sort of goes away is a box of
donuts or something right
and so chocolate covered i don't care
what's yeah
any donuts are so good so if for
somebody listening here
you you you were scared
you felt it it's easy to blow by that
and say
and then i had this moment of peace and
then i i exhaled and then i turned
around
no we didn't turn around yeah what what
does that fear
like you remember those days going out
and that anger you having somebody cut
your water off but they also there's
that indignation and i'm going to break
the rules but i got to water my family
needs water right
like walk somebody through the the heart
racing right well
and it's it's um just because you're at
the bottom doesn't mean the
transformation's over
no i saw the other day so
this man has hit rock bottom and a p
appears to be digging
yeah and so i mean it was 1988 september
when we filed bankruptcy we started the
radio show in 1992
june so that's almost four years later
uh wrote financial peace you know
three years later so something happened
during those other three years you know
what you know how are we sure it's
happening and that's the that's the uh
you know that's the period between the
old testament the new testament it's the
maccabees you know i mean yeah right so
it's the uh uh the the quiet time
uh the the silent period or whatever you
call it but uh there's a healing
a cocooning a growing uh
uh you know picking the scabs off
and all of that process that's um
you know sharon and i uh when we hit our
10
you know when all that stuff was
happening we would have been married at
in
uh we got married in 82 so in
88 we've been married six years when we
hit bottom
so um at the 10 year mark
we almost divorced right four years
after it all happened
why because we were too concentrated on
freaking existing
right to even worry about having a
feeling
or being wronged or having any rights or
anything else but once we healed up
enough we got enough
money uh then we went you know i don't
like you
yeah it's like and she's like by the way
back then you pissed me off and i'm like
that's four years ago get over it you
know
but no and so we end up in marriage
counseling for for four years trying to
survive and learn how to be married now
again
uh or for the first time in a new way
with a new set of certain new set of
rules and circumstances so that all is
going on during that quiet
period so to speak um and really bleeds
over into the early days of when they
started this show
and uh not this show but the dave ramsey
show
uh back in the day or the money game it
was called back then so
how does an east tennessee guy who's got
you have to have some swagger
to become a 26 year old real estate
mogul
and then falls off and then is
immediately into
hustling again i got to feed this family
yeah i have a choice
how in the world does that guy
um summon the humility to go to a
therapist therapist was not a thing back
then
that was you i mean no it was
no there wasn't a marriage therapist on
every corner like there is now no
and uh but you know
basically we're going we i looked at it
like going to class
okay like i learned some new tools like
i don't know how to do this
so i need somebody to teach me how to do
this yeah that's a special level of
humility dave
well i didn't know how to do it i mean
it wasn't it was it was
it was not i guess it was not like i
think i know how but i'm going to be
humble no it wasn't it was like
i don't know what the crap i'm doing
here i mean i didn't know how to be
married
and i certainly didn't know how to be
married but from a christian perspective
and so i'm studying scriptures and
you know we're going to christian
marriage retreats
and christian marriage weekends and
seminars and
this stuff and so i'm learning the
scriptural concepts of this and
and you know i'm starting to learn how
to apply them and
you know but but uh uh
you know and i'm dying and being reborn
literally in so many facets of my life
but certainly spiritually
uh in that process and so i it really
wasn't it was more like
uh and it wasn't really like this
desperate thing but it was
i don't know how to fix this and i don't
have
and the manual i've got is confusing
so i need somebody to guide me through
the manual and it was just for me it was
like a practical thing
if it makes any sense but yeah and i
didn't go to fix her
i did that i i i'll give myself a little
credit yeah
i didn't go i'm taking you to marriage
counseling to straighten you out
because i was well aware that the
majority of it was me and i also knew
enough about trauma
i wouldn't have called it that in those
days but i you know i studied enough
enough psych in school and that kind of
stuff to
get the idea that we've been through
hell and it affected both of us right
and so we were damaged goods trying to
two damaged people
i mean my insecurity was magnified off
the roof
because i'd lost all confidence and
competence as if i had any
and her uh her insecurity turned into
just sheer terror
she's afraid every move i was gonna make
was going to put us in the street yeah
and rightly so it had you know so you
know we had to work through
some did you have a family map for that
or were you out in the woods on this we
were in the woods
i mean we had church family but i mean
you didn't have like a um
a mom or dad that went through stuff and
you saw them treat each other this way
or my
answer my parents are you know her
parents and my parents stayed married
their whole lives
they were there you know but that's all
we knew we didn't know how they did it
right yeah you know uh and we knew and
we knew it was messy
of course how you do it because it is
always messy right uh if you think it's
not messy you're lying
yeah that's right so um you know or you
haven't been married alone um
or whatever i had a lady come up and
said i had never had a fight with my
husband in 35 years and i said that's
because you're a liar
right you know it's like you know the
book lines
she does he does drugs people stuff say
in book lines right
but um but yeah that and so that's all
in that
pretext and really that hasn't changed
because like you know i start running a
business and i'm going
i don't know what i'm doing so i got to
get you know john maxwell in my corner
and i got to get
henry cloud in my corner i got to get
and i didn't even know these men i start
reading their stuff they become friends
later but
because but but they yeah i had to have
a guide
to lead me through the forest on these
different things that i didn't know
and i'm still looking i i i don't look
for a singular mentor i don't believe in
that these i need someone to be my
mentor
thing i don't do this stuff but um but i
do i do look at a guy and go hey he's
got a good marriage okay dude what are
you doing
or that guy's good look at his kids
turned out how'd you do that
you know because i'm afraid to kill mine
so
how do you let them live and they turn
out you know it does
sound so april speak we'll see like i
need to learn how to
how to fix this vacuum that guy knows
how i'm going to call that guy
that's a that's an increase it's always
been rare and it's an increasingly
rare earth thing because now we've got
these little boxes in our phones that
tell us that we know everything we can
just google it right well you know but
there's not a lot of people
in it it is a type of humility but it's
not this
but what happened was i have the benefit
of being humiliated
by being this crushing experience going
through losing everything
and so there was nothing left
uh that said dave knew anything right
and so it was really easy to go i don't
know how to do that
because obviously i don't do anything
you know kind of thing so you know
and so starting from that point it but
that kid that was
a arrogant little you know
25 year old 24 year old whatever uh
would not have gone to counseling
because he would not have been wrong
about anything
okay so when i've made
stupid mistakes says stupid things we we
had a joint conference a zoom conference
with my kids with hank school today
and after the meeting i told sheila hey
i want to join that zoom and she just
looked at me with that one pause and i
said i want embarrasses
and so we had the zoo meeting and i
texted her after did i embarrass this
and she wrote no and that that nope and
i was like okay good
um you can go home tonight i'm good yes
i can sleep inside so when we do
dumb things or stupid things i wear my
shame right i
i have to deal with me i've gotta and my
tendency is like you i need to surround
myself by people who know how to do
things i know how to do and i love
that's one of my favorite things about
being alive
but my wife i've learned over the years
where's it too
in a different way how did to the best
of you understand
how was sharon walking through this
as someone who'd hitched her wagon to a
smooth talking
yeah multi-millionaire then then wasn't
yeah um
i mean her first thing she would tell
you was that she was terrified
that the experience terrified her and so
we had to put um marriage counseling did
this and common sense did this too we
had to put rules
in our life that
keep me from doing something without her
agreement
that's going to terrify her and so uh
for instance we don't spend over 500
either one of us
without first talking about it to this
day
we do live on a budget yeah yeah i'm
worth hundreds of millions of dollars
and i don't spend over 500 without
talking to my wife i never go and just
buy something
now we these days with the zeros we'd
live with we
are less and less concerned about it you
know if she wants to buy a repurse that
costs more than it should i'm
no big deal because that means i get
another gun but yeah
so a little trade-off here but uh you
know but it's not uh
so it's not like you know we're but in
the old days it was like
here we go again it was like you're
scamming and scheming again that's what
she would say
and so i don't know if that gives you
insight into her mindset or not
i don't think sh i you would have to ask
her to be sure but i
didn't read her as shame
that was me but she didn't cause it
she just was hitched to it yeah you know
now she was like at a family reunion
with her
family the fact that we were bankrupt
now that she might have felt shame with
that but even with our friends and stuff
she's like well he's just an idiot you
know
[Laughter]
i mean i mean maybe not exactly that not
that raw but i mean she is just like
she'll call it she just calls it like it
is she didn't feel like she caused it
because she didn't
okay and so uh but but except to the
extent that she didn't speak up
and uh years later she found her voice
and it works real well now but um
but she didn't speak up she was just
kind of the southern belt whatever you
want to do honey
and then later on she go but i knew it
wasn't gonna work and i'm like well why
don't you say anything you're dead gum
genius
till after the fact but um so we just
don't do stuff but when
but we're both in agreement and uh we
don't make large
philanthropic gifts we do a lot of
giving to ministry through our family
foundation
it's all structured with family all
speaks into it our kids speak into it
sharon and i are in agreement and if one
of my buddies calls up that's got a
ministry and goes hey i need ten
thousand dollars for this if there's
even if i know there's room in the
budget i
email sharon and denise my daughter's
the director of the foundation i'm going
so-and-so's wanting ten thousand dollars
i think we've got in the budget i think
we ought to do it what do y'all think
now i easily can make that decision i
make hundreds of thousands of
decisions around the company every day
without talking to
them i run it through the leadership
team here but
but the accountability back to that
keeps me from walking up on thin ice
that activates her old scars
her old wounds and would you for both of
you are they still there somewhere
oh yeah yeah there i mean will be the
rest of our lives
less and less the more and more padding
you had over them
and the more distance you have the more
healed they are uh i mean if you'd ask
us two years later or
five years later it felt a lot different
for both of us um
and uh you know i've worked past
that shame and worked past that uh
the insecurity and the humiliation
that i put myself through by owning it
but also
by not doing it anymore and i'm not that
guy anymore right
so i'm not that i'm not you know i'm
i'm a better dad i'm a better husband
i'm a better
i'm not not arrived don't get me wrong
i'm a better leader
than i was when i started and so uh that
that allows me to give myself grace yeah
so
that leads me to an identity question
two-fold one is
my default setting if you will
is when things get bananas in other
people's life
i head in like that's just how i'm wired
i'm gonna head on in when things get
bananas in my life my default setting is
to
just fade out just withdrawal yours
feels like it's the exact opposite yeah
i go straight in you go like i'm gonna
go swinging
where where does that come from i know
where mine comes from where does
where does that tendency to
oh boy here we go
i don't know um could be upbringing uh
it could be family dna or is it nurture
or nature i don't you know
how do you i don't know how do you i
mean i you know i grew up in a
neighborhood that if
if you know where
you know two little boys are getting a
fight i don't do that now
right okay but i mean come on too
12 year old boys you come on black eye
or bloody nose or something
you know your lips welled up and your
parents first question is well did you
win or what'd you say yeah yeah you know
or who was it and you know whose dad do
i need to call to
make sure we're all good you know it's
but it's not like and the parents are
all laughing about it you know they but
today it would be like a dead gum
facebook drama or something right or the
hoa would be called in or something but
some kind of helicopter parenting but um
i mean we just bust george's lip if
george mouthed off
and so when there's a when there's
something coming at you you reach and
you fight in other words so there's
probably some of that in there and i
still do some of that
obviously i don't bust people in the
mouth anymore
except in my fantasies but
that's another show that's another but
but i don't i mean i haven't
hit anybody in 40 years so life's pretty
good but so how do you
i have to when i feel myself going
heading back i have to
i've got a whole routine now this is
real quick
and i can do it real time nope
the most responsible ethical right faith
honoring things to go in
this time yeah how do you not go in not
going yeah
you have a process or do you have is
that just routine over years or
discipline or
people in your life what is it you know
again i i've um
because there's there's uh a lot of
fight or flight
kind of uh psychology in this and
physiological
yeah things in there um as well
and uh and so i had to study and go okay
from my
background from my natural wiring or my
wiring um if i if i'm going to reach
over and
jump into the fight i need to stop and
think about is it a fight
or did i just decide it was i mean is
this
and so it's uh it uh early in
my adult life i had a tremendous temper
and anger and um it was a big
part of my spiritual transformation by
the time i was 30 that it was gone
and i'm really passionate loud and
gregarious and sometimes people who are
a little more
laid back and receive me
as anger but it's not anger guys very
seldom get really really really like out
of control
rage type anger like pulse rate goes up
eyes dilate and sweat you know
we're on it now yeah it's game on i
almost never because i
it was such a spiritual exercise for me
early in my faith walk
to get that under control because the
the the
the wrathful man in proverbs doesn't
have much good happen for him nope
and he had to be uh uh he
he had i had to die to him and he had to
grow up and
uh so i i very seldom lose my i mean
in 30 years of running this company i
have completely lost it
with a team member two times
two times yeah you know and uh and
and they were not good and i i can
recount them and it's like
going on a bender or something you know
you go yeah i ain't never drinking that
again
you know and so it was not a fun trip
for me or them
that's fascinating because i can
remember two or three times
four or five times over the last several
years
when i kept my mouth shut and i
shouldn't have
and i leaned back and i should have you
know i mean and so it haunts me in that
same way
right this opposite reverse action
and so it just becomes part of your
spiritual walk your
uh psychological uh growth pattern to go
okay i'm gonna grow up because children
act like that
yeah children shrink back when they
should step in or children
reach over and bloody somebody's nose
right you know and and that that's a
childish
reaction that is not an adult reaction
that's someone who has no self-control
and self-control is a fruit of the
spirit for those of us that are
christians
so the second part of that identity is
this
i do ever almost every caller to the
show
almost everybody i've met with over the
years they carry the worst thing that's
ever happened to them
the worst thing they've ever done the
worst thing someone's ever said to them
it weaves its way into their dna it
becomes them
and it informs how they talk how they
think about themselves how they treat
other people etc
you've had to walk a it seems like
you've had to walk a really thin line
between
taking this worst thing that happened
and which is bankruptcy the
humility rising up from that but you
built a company on it
and you continue to tell that story yet
it does not define you
give some wisdom on how you've made that
transition because that to me is the
is the is one of the biggest challenges
i don't know
how i did it but now i i take the same
calls
in the sense that i hear the same thing
um uh
i think somebody cheats on their wife 10
years ago and they can't get over it
i the the question is have you grieved
it and have you healed from it
and if you haven't it is still your
identity okay um i don't know how i did
that but
something allowed me through this
process and again it was a
spiritual transformational time in my
life as well it's very rich
and i'm getting over having a temper i'm
trying to learn how to be married i've
got young babies and i don't know how to
raise them i don't know what to do i
don't know how to act
and i'm having to learn how to do all of
these things as a man
and so in the midst of that somehow i
said
i gave myself some grief because of i
did some stupid butt stuff and i broke
we went broke it's my fault so i had to
own it
and then i had to grieve it uh and then
i had to heal from it and if you don't
heal from it it becomes your identity
and so i have people call the show and
they're like well you know the reason
i've got these financial problems is
i i went through a divorce and i've got
fifty thousand dollars in debt and i'm
like
and the divorce was just awful and it
just destroyed my life and
i'm like so how long ago was it 11 years
like 11 years
the way the language they were using was
11 months
right because they're it's still fresh
they still bathe in that acid
every day they have not moved past it
they're stuck in it well back then my
husband did so and so they're still
stuck in that and uh so you gotta cut
the
bad thing that happened to you whether
you brought it on yourself or not
loose and heal from it and grieve it and
i i probably wouldn't have used the word
grieving
uh six months ago but you've taught me a
lot about that just listening to you
take a call
on my show our show the ramsay show and
say well you have you grieved that and
i'm like well you know i mean it's okay
to grieve a loss even if it's a weird
loss
you know or if it's a teeny tiny one or
if it's a great big one right yeah it's
okay to just stop and recognize
that actually did hurt you know
instead of just keep running on that
same hurt ankle right you know it's like
you know well i had a really really nice
car
and i totaled it and well you can't talk
about a car
that nice and you're sad about it
because that makes you a jerk right
and so one of the most common things i
think you know i've talked about this
i've told
i've worked with you know doctors and
lawyers behind closed doors and
you're allowed to be sad that you
wrecked your lexus yeah it happened yeah
you're allowed to be sad that you're
like my maserati okay they all own it
you're allowed to be saying and it it
hurt my feelings because i liked that
car
but you can't tell people my maserati
because it makes you sound like you're
untouchable and you're too cool or
you're snobbish or something which it's
none of that i just wrecked my really
nice car and it hurts my feelings you
know
we live in this culture of comparative
grief yeah exactly i've got it worse
than you
yeah and you're not allowed to grieve
something like that no there's a cap
right if it's yeah it's like we're
talking about
oh well crimea river one percenter you
know
i remember dave i was doing my
dissertation i remember calling my
dissertation chair
saying i'm gonna have to talk about
something really controversial
in the defense and he said what is it
and i said
really powerful wealthy people get to be
sad too
and they get to have good marriages too
and be sad when their marriages aren't
working
and in fact if they can be well and
whole everybody's well and whole because
they run every
it was just like you know what i mean
and he was like
okay you know it was this whole oh yeah
wait a minute man
if if we're going to yeah if we're going
to be about helping people be well but
it goes back to
man i keep thinking this word over and
over dave
you have this supernatural capacity to
forgive yourself
and i think many people don't aren't
able to do that
to forgive yourself to forgive the
circumstances to forgive whatever and
then go about being what tomorrow's
going to be
yeah and that's a real that's a gift of
practice and i think
it ha again people often ask me about a
lot of different things and i will go
back to going broke i have the
inordinate benefit of having gone broke
early in my life
and i think it gives you that yeah if
that had happened a different way
at a different time in my life i might
not have that it reminds me of a
kickboxing coach that would put you
against somebody way ahead of you and
say
when you know the worst that can happen
yeah
yeah when you're then you're free to
actually get in there and spar and start
throwing bunches of kids
there's all kinds of stories that relate
that you know but it's um
but i i you know there's what is this
show uh
ted lasso oh you know what about
goldfish
yeah goldfish right yes yeah yeah yeah
so what's that what's the animal with
the shortest memory a goldfish be a
goldfish
so we can get into this one this is a
fun question here
so a common question that i get asked
either on the instagrams or through the
emails
is uh tohono you and dave
are different yeah
and so he's a lot smarter than i am yeah
right yeah right
and so one of the things like one of the
the
my loop arounds is always man i have
intentionally
just as a life practice surrounding
myself with people with different
beliefs in me
but who have the same values as i do
yeah and those are two
different things one of the things i
love about working with you is
you've got a i mean man i wrote this
question before we talked about
before i knew about your desire to learn
stuff you seem to
crave other people's insights into
things
whether you incorporate it or not is is
a whole other conversation but you
like to know hey how did you do that
tell me about this
like how are you thinking you think i'm
wrong are you with me
yeah yeah i relish that that is a
for someone who's achieved your success
that is a
a freakishly rare thing what drives that
uh i don't want to make mistakes anymore
i don't want to mess that up i don't
want to mess this up i want to know how
this works
and um you said the guy that takes the
i was the kid that took the radio or
took the i took
my dad out of junk lawnmower and i took
every bolt out of it and took the engine
apart
to learn how the engine worked i had to
know and i don't know
why that was and the next door neighbor
was mean
and um he's like uh you want to learn
how spark plug works
oh and um he said here hold this and he
pulled the lawnmower through and knocked
me
out fell backwards that's a hard shock
right there it's worse than
worse than a light socket but um yeah
and but i'll never touch spark plug wire
again nope no i was 10. you never listen
to a neighbor either i never listen to
that guy again about anything you know
here pull my finger you know right
but the uh uh but it seems like the idea
that i have to know how it works and i
i it you know uh
this enneagram stuff everybody's
studying i you know i i am
the quintessential eight and eight is a
challenger and i get intimacy
by arguing i enjoy
that and so rachel and i just for sport
yeah
argue we're the worst the two of us we
do it on the air
and we do it at the cathy at the uh
easter table
last sunday you know and so uh i mean
the rest of them are all just watching
you know and it's just like would you sh
you're just you know
you know you're just a conspiracy theory
girls come on
so i mean it's you know her and her
conspiracy theories but the uh
yeah i get intimacy from that it doesn't
i don't
um it's a it's a rare i'm not
mad i'm just inquisitive
yeah but sometimes people take that
conflict process that i use to get
information
as anger and like we're going to lose
relationship or something over it oh
no this relationship that actually
increases it gotcha
man i wish you could so one of the the
great relational terms i always want
couples to make is going from
judgment to curiosity when he said that
thing before you bite his head off
stop and don't judge it and say hey tell
me what you meant by that
or vice versa right you responded to
that text from that woman
before i go off the handle tell me about
it
right or okay let's to have this kind of
date before you freak out and call your
friend like
that if you could write that book dave
i'm telling you man people
cannot it's a rare thing to enter into
especially when you quote unquote have
made it right
to say ah tell me about that instead of
just impose will
impose will impose will and that's the
thing that i i've
um i love working with you i had our
link letter
on the air he was here in person before
he passed
away uh inordinately successful
in like three different fields
people knew him from he was a
contemporary of walt disney walt disney
was one of his personal friends and he's
telling stories on the air and i was
just enamored
and he was 88 years old when he was here
and he did 78 speaking engagements that
here
i'm like why why
you know well when you stop learning and
growing
you are dead whether you do that at 40
or whether you do that at 140.
but he said you might as well stay
engaged because there's all kinds of
aging data
on the brain that says that it is a
muscle and it atrophies
when you don't use it and he said you
know i'm doing 78 speaking engagements
and i'm
writing another book this year and um
he's 88 years old and he didn't need to
financially he didn't need to from a
notoriety standpoint he was an icon at
that point
but it was just to stay engaged and just
to continue to grow because if you're
not growing you're dying
so there's that yeah i just i think
that's
i think that's one of the greatest
things you can one of the greatest gifts
you can bestow upon yourself and those
around you is that
constant tell me how that works let's
take that apart yeah how's it how's that
lawnmower
how does that work how's that lawn mower
work here hold the spark plug
so what makes you a good dad
and i know it's a different question you
got grown kids versus little kids
i got an 11 year old and a six-year-old
what makes a good dad or made me one you
yeah um well i i was not a great dad
um i was a good dad uh and uh
the the and i got substantially better
in time
just in time before before the formative
years were completely gone and before
teenagers needed to be executed and so
um we laughingly say our kids turned out
because of the nurturing of their mother
and the fear of their father
um but that you know obviously they were
not
afraid all the time quaking in their
boots from me
um but we had
uh sharon and i both gave them very firm
boundaries
okay um we did not want to create
be disciplinarians to the point that you
create stepford children
uh my friend andy anders says you want
to raise children who become good adults
you don't want to raise good kids
hmm so you're playing a long game mm-hmm
and so that you know and that affects
how
if you let them oh yeah step over there
you
don't do it you know i'm gonna let you
and yeah there
you see there it hurt didn't it you know
grab a spark plug wire right and so you
know you learn those lessons permanently
when you do that
uh but uh you give them enough rope to
find it but not so much rope that they
can be
permanently damaged and harmed and um
but they had real firm boundaries our
kids um
but they weren't like i mean there's
always the kids
and i guess there's a spectrum in the
neighborhood we had the you know you
have the hippie parents i call them and
the kids just run wild right
it's anarchy you know like the two
little boys on uh
uh what's the wonderful nascar thing
with will
oh uh uh ricky bobby uh
ricky yeah those two boys those two kids
that's the anarchy kids right
anarchy you know and so uh until grandma
comes in and puts something right
and sets them straight that's kind of
how i grew up you know so
uh uh but the the parents that don't
believe in giving their children any
boundaries
and so they raise animals not not humans
not adults
and then there's the parents who put so
many boundaries
and so and they make all their decisions
for them that the children develop no
critical thinking skills
and they can't make a decision a moral
decision in the moment they can't make a
physical harm decision in the moment
because they've never made any decisions
ever and that's the the the stuff i call
them stafford children well
i'm thinking of the graduate student
parents who would call and ask for
yeah homework assignments and it's like
your kid's 25. what are you doing
you know you know when we have them call
here when their
28 year old is interviewing and they
want to talk to hr and we're like
well i think we settled that pretty much
not hiring this one you know helicopter
mother oh my god woman
and so uh yeah there's that uh they do
everything
for him one of my friends is a counselor
called them lawnmower parents they not
only helicopter
for them but they mow out the russians
so they can walk right straight through
and you know you so you
they they don't have any muscle
structure or uh
any bone structure in their character to
make a decision with
but they also weren't allowed to just
run loose and so there were consequences
and
moral things as believers as christians
that
we demanded right you're not going to do
this right
and they were physically afraid of
violating those boundaries yeah
so what would you go back and do
different
i would have been more affirming i don't
mind being tough but i would have been
more affirming what does that mean
i just would have spent more time more
hugs i did plenty of hugs
i was i was there i was emotionally
present those kinds of things but i
would have been warmer
warmer in general and just by that i
mean bragged on them more directly
i did that later as i found it but i
mean it would have been
like one of our granddaughter's um
birthday is one of rachel's daughter's
birthday and
we did the happy birthday on easter and
the whole table you know it's 14 of us
sitting there seven kids or six kids and
eight adults and everything and i'm just
looking at little amelia and just
speaking into her
how wonderful she is and how proud papa
dave is of her
and how smart she is and how pretty she
is and you're gonna
be a big deal kid you're amazing
and just that little 30 second thing
that kid
lit up like a bulb man and her daddy
does that all the time and her mama does
that all the time papa dave did it too
though this time and so
bragging on myself but i wish i'd done
more of that when mine was that age
well so here's how we'll redeem that
today i had a conference like i said
with my kids school
and i got off that conference i just
thought man
what a great little 10 11 year old kid
yeah and here's what i wouldn't have
done i would have gone home and told him
that and i'm not going to tell him yeah
i got this i got to peek behind his
curtain yep hands and
on his face that's his face look at his
eyes yeah yeah yeah
and by the way he's a great kid oh he's
yeah he's awesome he could shoot a
shotgun
too so yes we were out shooting clays
that little turkey's popping him man
i mean he don't miss yeah he's better
shot in his daddy that's a low bar man
but
all right so here's the last thing um
when i was deciding whether to work here
i don't even know if you remember this
um i had worked with
um not in the media world but i'd worked
behind closed doors with
folks who they call me and say hey
deloney i'm
president of such and such i'm this and
this
i think i've done the thing that's going
to get me in trouble or get me fired and
i need some
talk through this with me one of the
most common things that became
like just i just started beating this
drum years ago
it was you gotta have people
the the more successful you are the
lonelier you get
and so i don't even know if you remember
this one of the questions i asked you in
our interview
was who do you listen to who do you hang
out with and you rattled off three or
four different groups and i
left and i remember calling sheila on
the way home my wife on the way home and
said
um dave and i were gonna disagree about
stuff and i don't even
fully know what this job is but i trust
him
and um but i trust him and because he's
got people
speaking to him it's been my experience
that
there's a shift that happens when you
become successful so you get your
medical degree and you become a doctor
and you have your same buddies from med
school and you have your wife's friends
or your husband's friends and y'all hang
out
and then suddenly you buy the practice
and then you and two partners buy the
other practice
and then pretty soon your house gets a
little bit bigger and your car gets
nicer
and then people start going to your
house because
it's your house not because they're
gonna hang out with you and they start
waiting for your
fill in the blank your party you have
the coolest halloween
stuff or whatever and then slowly they
those intimate little hey bring whatever
casserole you got whatever half bottle
of wine you gotta come over to my house
those start going away because they just
turned into shows productions
have you experienced in your arc the
tightening of that circle
or a loneliness or you seem to really
cultivate
people around you i've experienced it
um it has the opportunity to do that and
the reason it does that is not because
you um
uh seek isolation or something but uh
everyone goes through an evolution of
friends yeah
if your only friends when you're 50
are your high school buddies that's a
problem your uncle rico on napoleon
dynamite okay
i mean you know so that's just you
should have outgrown
some of those people and here's this i
remember
or they should have outgrown you or we
should have had
value based you know disagreements that
don't allow us to have real close
intimate conversations anymore
and this is important thing to to i had
buddies that you know
they're doing cocaine still and i'm 60.
so they're not my buddies right i mean
i'm not mad at them i'm not mean to them
i don't shame them
but i don't need them hanging out of my
house right
i remember a buddy of mine became a
college president and
suddenly we didn't i didn't go to the
fights anymore he didn't have us over
yeah
and i remember thinking that's the
rightest smartest thing for this guy to
do
because delony's a hothead and
especially 15 years ago
i'm gonna say something stupid about
when i was over so so he
there was a natural evolution on behalf
of the of this well i wasn't
that makes sense yeah but i'm not
guarding this place or guarding our
lives that's not what i'm saying i'm
saying that
the the you're gonna have a few people
that make it all the way through your
life with you and then you're gonna
develop
new friends as you grow and change right
that you have intimacy with
in in terms of an intimate conversation
i mean not sexual intimacy
but the uh but the uh uh you know and so
i'm sharon and i are going to dinner
tonight with a couple that we have hung
out with for 35 years
so they're on the inside of the inside
they knew dave ramsey before there was a
dave ramsey right
they were there when i was going broke
you know and so uh and we're still good
friends but the guy reads like a maniac
i mean he's not uber business successful
but but very successful and uh so i
don't go to him for business insights
um because our scale is different but uh
so that's a guy from way back but then
i'm you know
i i'm perfectly content with
uh henry cloud is a really good personal
friend and that's happened in the last
uh eight years yeah you know and not
35-year relationships an eight-year
relationship but henry and i email
once a month once a week about something
trading some stupid joke or whatever and
um anytime i'm in la we're hanging out
or he's over here we're hanging out and
he does events with us and we hang out
with him and
um what's your trust metric when is it a
gradual thing or do you oh definitely
okay definitely and i'm looking uh i'm
looking for authenticity i struggle with
that
authenticity i struggle with because i
can smell i can smell a fake
yeah my way i'm not real discerning on
things
it's easy to lie to me i've been lied to
a lot
um and people get away with it they want
to impress you right well or period just
not not just
me but i'm just in general my my ability
to detect that's horrible
but uh my ability to detect a fake i can
just
i can walk in the room and just go yeah
because i was one
uh huh you're just you know you're just
you're just acting like you know
just if we could buy you for what you're
worth and sell you for what you think
you're a son you'd be something you know
we make some money on you
but no they're not he's not a real dude
or she's not a real dude i can smell
those putting on the dog and the plastic
stuff
and oh god man just be real
just go you know i'm just some days suck
some days don't we're just you know
let's have some meatloaf put a little
ketchup on it and
white beans and cornbread and you know
um
and we'll just sit down here and and
talk together and hang out we may laugh
about stupid stuff we may
tell 13 year old boy jokes we may
whatever but let's just you know if for
god's sakes be real
yeah how do you
i just i feel like in my life the
temptation is to always go home and just
shut the door
do you get energy from being alone or
you get energy from other people oh i'm
an extrovert i get energy okay other
people sharon gets energy from being
alone so it keeps us balanced
so so i don't over do that and i don't
like the uh
social uh setting the uh
the classic party where you stand around
you know the drink in your hand what do
you do and i don't give a crap you know
all that stuff that drives me bananas
i'm but i but to sit down and hang
yeah with people that i love and the
thing
back to your other question a minute ago
i want to add to it right quick um
because i think it's a principle other
people can use and i would suggest it
um as you grow don't be afraid to
ask people that are slightly or even
much more successful than you at a given
thing
into your life if you can if they're
authentic if they're real
right uh because you'd be amazed at
that all these successful people are are
uh
really all success is is a pile of all
the mistakes you've made and you're
standing on it rather than laying under
it
gotcha so they have all climbed a
mountain of garbage to
understand you know that they have all
shoveled you know the more
new levels new devils right that you
know they have shoveled manure at levels
that you hadn't shoveled it maybe
and they have hurt at levels you haven't
hurt they've been betrayed and lied
about it maybe at levels you haven't yet
and
uh don't be afraid to hang out with them
if they'll be real
yeah now you know i know people in show
business or
radio or leadership training or whatever
that aren't they're fakie
but but though i'm amazed at somebody
like at a henry cloud level uh who sold
10 million books you know
uh that a guy like that or i can name
other names i'll start dropping names
i'm not gonna do that but
but these guys that are uber successful
they
need and want friendship too yes
that's my thing and so if you just ask
like the first time i did that was
20 years ago i formed an eagles group we
called it
and um i made a list of men
that i knew well and men that i just
knew
who they were and i knew they had a good
marriage
i knew they were walking with god at
some level
and i knew that they had some level of
success
in their field they were music people
they were pastors
of good size organizations uh they were
authors they were business people of
some kind
and i emailed 12 guys and some of them
were like
studs i mean eagles you know and i was
like wow
if i could just the fact that i could
get their email was kind of like
intimidating
man and i asked 12 of them to get
together once a week and study the bible
or read a book and just talk and be guys
together
and just create a group of guys for just
to love each other
and encourage each other and be
accountable to over time as we built
relationship
just a short email like that you know
how many of them came
the first meeting all of them wow and
these are household names
these are if i started naming them off
people today
you know people would know who i was
talking about about 9 out of 12 or
household names
and uh one of the guys i'm having dinner
with tonight you know the same
so he's still that group that group
lasted 12 years
but but what my point is is that
don't be afraid to ha invite people into
your life
that are new that are that
that have that they have the stuff
because they need it too and i i
i know they need it they most of my time
my experience been they desperately want
it
yeah they heard for it yeah and many of
us go back to middle school
i don't care how successful we are i
didn't get invited to that so i'm just
gonna i'm gonna head home
and and i'm just gonna that's i'm good
i'm cool and the car is getting ready
and the the dinners get nicer but you're
still by yourself right yeah and man i
would love to be included into a thing
we all want to be including a thing
but again it goes back dave
i i talk to a single mom i talk to a dad
who just wants to be a better husband i
talk to
fill in the blank fill in the blank
feeling blank and they the expectation
is these things just happen
and what you just described was a highly
intentional
i need this i i
am valued enough that i need other
people and i'm gonna do the work
get these guys email addresses i'm gonna
set it up i'm gonna go first it goes
back to that
well and i knew that as we grew that i
would go
back to your earlier question that i
would go into isolation because i'd be
too cool for school potentially
and that that's where people crash
that's that's it that's when leaders die
this is where leaders go to die
isolation and arrogance
and secret lives off to the side and
think that nobody sees this stuff well
god sees it
and um and you know you're not getting
away from it yeah and so i knew
uh i have the benefit of a wife who is
not impressed at all with dave ramsey
i have that same i have the same
blessing and so that's a good starting
point for accountability and then i had
that group of guys and
when that group broke up i formed
another group with a little different
mindset
and a little different thing but still
with the same idea of
deep relationships with men who will
call you out right
and so when you know when ramsay's
getting hammered in the press
you know who's emailed me those 11 guys
okay
six of them will carry my casket yeah
and and
that man that's a great one to leave on
here but
going all the way back to
every single person i've ever met has
crashed
maybe not as spectacularly as as you did
everybody crashes everybody messes up
everybody well
moral crash is more what i was concerned
about or integrity crash
i'm saying all arrogance back to your
your bankruptcy right yeah yeah
we all are growing and i don't care how
small you think your situation is or how
quote-unquote big it is you're in a big
building with your name on it
it goes back to that intentionality i'm
going to surround myself with people who
know stuff i don't know because i want
to learn i'm going to surround myself
people who are going to teach me to be a
better husband better dad better
business leader better whatever
i'm going to surround myself with i'm
going to go first and practice
friends and that sounds so dumb right
because when you're a kid they just
shove
my kids will play with any rando our
kids hang out with rachel's kids the
other day
took eight minutes and then they're off
telling stories and i don't know what
they're doing
right yeah it's weirder with us right
with grown-ups we have too many shells
and layers and whatnot
it's going first and saying i deserve to
have friends well you're so
desperate to be impressive that you're
not that you impress nobody because
you're alone right
well you're not impressive because
you're fake yes so you're just
you're putting up all this stuff instead
of just going hey
there's some good air and there's some
bad get ready man i'm bringing the
casserole out yeah exactly
right yeah it's beautiful well brother
thanks for your time it's
super valuable honored to have you and
listen i'm so proud of what you're doing
here thanks man
absolutely amazing i listen to podcasts
on my runs on my walks in the morning
and
uh you're taking some weird calls and
you're taking some good
calls and you're helping a lot of people
and i'm so
proud of the doctor john dolone show and
dr john dolone in the
healthcare appreciate people and i'm
proud it's part of our team here well
i'm grateful for you man
and for the the listeners i there was a
moment when i said
um that exact thing dave i don't i don't
know what this job is
and you're asking me to i'm gonna leave
something that i've worked for
15 20 years to do i've never done this
and you said
trust me i knew you could do this and
man i'm so grateful that i did i knew
this was going to be bad
and it's just begun man it's just going
to be my silly little thing we're doing
here
it's wild man get ready baby hold on
well i'm grateful for we appreciate you
baby hold on i know my father-in-law
rode bulls man
he's been telling me that for years all
right appreciate you man have a good
night you too brother take care
thank you so much for sticking around
and listen to my interview with my
friend and boss
dave ramsey listen i said at the
beginning of the show we were not gonna
have
song lyrics of the day uh i asked dave
what his favorite songs were and he was
like eagles and
some older songs listen here's his
favorite song
it doesn't even have lyrics it's that
baker street saxophone song that goes at
the beginning starts beginning of
every single dave ramsey show every
single ramsay show
so instead of lyrics of the day i'm
gonna i'm just gonna just gonna i'm just
gonna bring it from my heart
it's more trumpety than saxophony i
think is that the
you sound like the monkey in the jungle
book doing a
trumpet solo rude i'm rocking the baker
street saxophone
[Music]
not a saxophone it is a saxophone it's a
woodwind it'll work it's in the song but
that what you just said was not
i don't even think a trumpet's a
woodwind stance cool don't do drugs this
has been the dr john delony
show